hello everybody it is great to be back
it is seven o'clock here in the uk
welcome wherever you're watching us
around the world
let's crack on a rebellion brewing over
foreign aid cuts does the prime minister
face defeat will ask one of his
own mps david davis who's joined that
rebellion
as well as the shadow foreign secretary
lisa nandy and from the government today
solicitor
general uh that's lucy fraser plus we'll
speak to the former prime minister
gordon brown about covid and the g7 also
for you this morning
here we go uh one year on from the
toppling of that statue in bristol
we'll get the reflections of the city's
mayor that's marvin reese that's at half
past eight for you on the program this
morning
and lucy's law close to my heart the
possible new measures
to tackle exploitative imports of
poppies into the uk
we're joined by the tv vet mark abraham
at a quarter to nine it's monday the 7th
of june
tory rebels ramp up the pressure on the
pm as they push for a common vote
to overturn the reduction of foreign aid
spending
swipe right if you've been jabbed how
leading dating apps have teamed up with
the government to encourage people
to get their covid vaccine
big lockdown easing in ireland and wales
today but questions continue
in england about whether the 21st of
june
will in fact be freedom day
michaela cole wins big at the tv bafta
awards for i may destroy you
calling on the industry to help end
abuse of power
and plenty of dry sunny and warm weather
once again for today
but there will be some sharp showers too
i'll have the details for you later
[Music]
good morning we start with a potential
problem for the prime minister who is
under pressure from a group of around 30
conservative mps
who could today force a vote to reverse
his planned reduction in foreign aid
spending
rebels say the reduction will lead to
hundreds of thousands of preventable
deaths
worldwide my trusty wing woman tamara
cohen
is here hi hi kate hello well looks like
boris johnson may have a major revolt on
his hands
a lot of conservative mps felt very
strongly that not only
was the aid cut last year going to be
devastating
in terms of the impact and lives lost in
poor countries
but also that this shouldn't have been
done without a vote in parliament
which was done because the government
insisted it was only going to be
temporary during the pandemic but now
those tories have spotted an opportunity
to amend a law that's going through
parliament at the moment to do with
setting up a scientific
research agency but they found a way to
try and force the government to use some
of that money
to reinstate the aid target if they
won't do it any other way
now i understand rishi sunak the
chancellor was himself calling tories
over the weekend
to try and talk them down because
they're so confident that they have the
numbers
all we need to see is whether that vote
will be allowed by the common speaker to
go ahead
and the supporters of it say the stakes
couldn't be higher
this is my report in fragile states like
south sudan
cuts to foreign aid are already being
felt sky news recently witnessed
how a devastating combination of
conflict climate change
and now the covid pandemic have left
millions of people
at risk of famine what this tells us is
really these are hot spots where people
are going to die
two-thirds of people in south sudan are
food insecure
and yet the uk has cut its aid there by
a third
and somewhere like yemen the world's
worst humanitarian catastrophe
cuts to uk aid has stood at 60
is the worst possible time for the uk to
be cutting back its support
how bad is it the chancellor announced
the cut last november
saying the crisis at home had to come
first
sticking rigidly to spending 0.7 of our
national income on overseas aid
is difficult to justify to the british
people
but today a group of conservative mps
who were determined to overturn that
decision
will join with labor and others to push
for a vote in parliament
and they believe they have the support
to force boris johnson's hand
we're trying to train them right through
to making the coffee
this tiny charity was just two staff
helping farmers in nepal
spent months applying for a government
grant and got through
only to be told it was scrapped those
communities they
they're already struggling we have um
you know a situation where
we have to talk to our ngo partners to
say i'm sorry this funding doesn't exist
anymore it's quite embarrassing you know
as a british citizen for that to happen
and you know what what does that do to
the uk's reputation
i guess overseas the government is still
spending 10 billion pounds
on global health and poverty this year
and many conservative mps
say there's plenty to be proud of 98
of all of the oxford astrazeneca vaccine
is going to be going
abroad to all of these countries which
we're talking about now
that's been that's been funded by you
know largely by uk government
research money now which isn't included
in our international
development aid spending so i think
there's you know we are putting a huge
amount
into supporting the world still now and
obviously at the moment we've got real
issues here in the uk
back in south sudan where uk funding for
health clinics has been cut
those on the ground say many lives are
dependent on these decisions
tamara cohen sky news happy to have lucy
fraser with us now she's the solicitor
general for england
and well tell you she thanks for joining
us hi let's start with foreign lots to
crack on with
i was listening to bob geldof yesterday
on the telly
and he was saying tory voters quoting
him are essentially prudent but they're
not cruel this cut
is cruel why do you think it isn't well
we are
last year we were the third largest
donor globally in terms of international
aid so we really do
pay a significant amount to help the
world generally
and even without the 0.7 this year
we will be investing 10 billion pounds
and that is really important but we're
in the middle of a pandemic
and it is really important that we
support
um the the effort here as well you know
the treasury has spent
407 billion pounds so what we've said is
of course international aid
needs to be spent but we're going to
temporarily
cease the 0.7 and bring it back when
fiscal circumstances allow it is a
global pandemic of course so g7
um in cornwall this weekend all the
other g7 uh countries are not cutting
their aid so why are we
it is a global pandemic and we have very
much
uh contributed to that effort so half a
billion pounds
very early on to it to support the
kovacs scheme
but not just that it's because of um the
effort that we put in the money that we
put in
uh to the astroven astrazeneca vaccine
let's talk about vaccines later on
it is a global pandemic the other g7
leaders are all continuing to pay
we are not it's going to be very
embarrassing for the prime minister if
he
if he doesn't win this vote when he goes
down to the g7 leaders and he's the only
one sitting there saying oh
sorry we're coming our starting point is
that we are one of these
most significant donors to international
aid so
so as i mentioned we are questioned the
third largest
uh in terms of donors internationally so
our starting point is very high
and we we absolutely uh think that that
is important but we have to consider the
circumstances
uh that we're in but it affects the
whole world
you know the other g7 leaders i'll put
the point again
are not cutting their aid one could
argue that um other countries
around the world sub-saharan africa and
the like were they need a lot of money
from us
then never more so than now and yet
we're saying
sorry we can't do that for now charity
starts at home
we were one of the first countries to
commit to the 0.7
so why well our international effort
isn't just about
giving money through international aid
so i've mentioned
the vaccine but it's not just that it's
also about boris johnson's leadership
where he said
already in relation to the vaccine that
we must ensure that the whole world gets
the vaccine
by the end of 2022. and we're going to
give that away are we as opposed to
giving it away at cost
we are going to we've committed to a
hundred million doses
we've committed to two billion pounds
worth of jabs
over the course of this year and next
are we giving it away are we giving it
away at cost
and well we've committed to two billion
pounds worth
of jabs um and uh i'm i'm not sure
whether that is at
cost or whether that is uh in relation
to
um the the jobs that will go my
understanding is that it's at cost and
not for free
can i just come in on that point because
it is really important to say the reason
that the whole world
and developing countries are getting it
at cost is because of
our investment as a country into the
astrazeneca vaccine in the first place
so
that's a massive effort that we've put
in already um
is it true that the chancellor has been
uh he's so worried about
potentially losing this vote today the
amendment to the vote that he's been
ringing conservative mps over the
weekend
i don't know what the chancellor's been
doing or hasn't been doing the
chancellor hasn't rang me but
when there's any count on your vote i'm
guessing well he can count on my vote in
relation to this matter because i think
it is really important
uh that we spend money at home uh at
this time
of the pandemic but it is usual of
course for ministers to
um take the temperature of back benches
and to talk to them
to understand their concerns talking
about taking temperatures there'll be a
lot of that going on at schools today as
the kids go back
um a lot of them i i heard mr hancock
say yesterday should have had the
lateral flow test before they went back
to school
the way to get around that is for the
kids to have their vaccines uh 12 to 15
year olds
when's that gonna be well the position
that we're in at the moment is that the
medicine regulator has determined that
it is safe and effective
for children to use the vaccine and
that's great news
and the next step is that the government
has already asked
the joint committee on vaccinations and
immunizations
to advisors on whether we should have a
national rollout
of the vaccine for 12 to 17 year olds do
you think it's a good idea
well i wait to see what the jcvi um
say we we have taken their advice
throughout the pandemic and i'm sure we
will take their advice on this as well
uh freedom day 21st of june is that
going ahead
well we will be looking at the data and
it is really important to look at the
data
before we make a decision and the data
that we'll be looking at
is you know the vaccination rate the
hospitalization rate
the the death rate as well as the number
of variants that we have in the country
at the time
listening to matt hancock yesterday it
sounded as though it's less likely than
it was
well we will look at the data and
there's a week to go
before we'll be making a determination
about june the 21st so all the data is
showing us at the moment
is that the level of infections are
going up but that isn't
translating into hospitalizations in the
way that it did
uh in the in the other ways so that's
good news but we have to keep looking at
the data you do look at the data
but we always know that it's the
politicians that make the decision in
the long run and there's all sorts of
considerations that you have to make not
least
uh those pesky rebel mps on your back
benches who will not be at all happy
if you push this freedom day back any
further um i suppose the prime minister
has to take all of that into account as
well does he well the prime minister has
to
look at uh the data in relation to the
situation
on the ground in terms of health that's
hospitalizations
um the vaccine roll out all the other
things i mentioned but it also has to
look at the economy
and the politics and the and the impact
on business and on people's
lives i'm sure that the prime minister
will be listening to back benches as he
will be listening to a variety of people
but really these decisions will be made
on relation to the data um
two other questions if i may um as far
as
uh president biden is concerned he's
coming down to the g7
in cornwall on friday saturday
um he has said that unless the deal
for northern ireland as far as brexit is
concerned is sorted out it's an absolute
mess
at the moment in fact we heard from the
brexit minister
um saying that the government
underestimated the effects of the
northern ireland
protocol on goods movements that there
will not be a deal between
the us and the uk on trade how could you
not have seen this coming
you were warned by three former prime
ministers and indeed uh the
the uh george mitchell who put together
the northern ireland agreement and the
cbi as well they all said
this is going to be a problem only now
is the brexit minister saying
looks like it's a bit of a problem and
the um the
american president is saying get it
sorted well lord frost is absolutely
trying to get it sorted and he was in
ireland last week
and doing exactly that it is very
difficult on the ground
in terms of trade um and you know it is
important that we ensure that we do have
uh trade between um between the uk
and and uh ireland between between
england and ireland
and it is really important that we saw
this and lord frost is doing exactly
that
but you understand that it does look as
though you underestimated the
complexities
of this agreement well as it has panned
out on the ground it is more difficult
than we anticipated and we do need to
sort out that trade arrangement and that
is what
lord frost is doing you weren't really
listening when
three former prime ministers george
mitchell and the cbi amongst others were
saying
this isn't gonna work i think we've
listened uh the whole way through but we
have
untangling our relationship uh with
europe which we had for
over 40 years was obviously going but it
was an oven ready deal
it was always going to be difficult and
no one underestimated
the problems um in relation to that
and we need to sort them out okay just
want to ask you um about
this dating app story that i've been
reading about
uh today so apparently you are going to
advertise
on dating apps to get more people to
have jabs is that right is it going to
say something like mature male with
sense of humor all his own teeth two
good hips
looking for long strolls in the open air
with potential life partner must have
two jabs
well what we know and the reason this is
really important is that
uh 59 of people would prefer to date
someone who'd been
vaccinated we know that the vaccine is
having an effect as i mentioned
it's breaking that chain between
infections and hospitalization so
getting your jab
is really important and if putting this
on a dating app
helps encourage that rollout and then
that's a great thing
you nearly smile i've been up since four
o'clock this morning working on that gag
it's lovely to see you thanks so much
for joining us really appreciate it
thank you
still to come on the program for you
this morning at 20 past seven
i'll be speaking to the shadow of
foreign secretary lisa nandi about those
proposed cuts to the uk's foreign aid
budget
[Music]
former prime minister gordon brown joins
us at half past seven he's adding his
voice to calls
for rich nations to pay to vaccinate
the entire world against covet 19.
[Music]
20 to 10 staycation successes we'll hear
from one of the businesses that's seeing
a steep rise in demand
due to more holidays at home
i thought my dating app was reasonably
funny
apparently you're swiping through a
dating app you may get more
than just a potential love match as the
government is using them to encourage
people to get
a covered jab our reporter melania
joining us now
uh live from the newsroom hello actually
it's lovely to see you i've been away
for six months i've forgotten how to
pronounce your surname and i didn't want
to mess it up remind me
it's vesseling rich but you said my
first name perfectly okay
let me tell you about these dating apps
matching with the government so
from today people will be able to
display a badge saying if they've been
vaccinated or they intend to do so and
return the dating apps will let them
have a boost
which lets them stand out among
potential matches take a listen to what
some young people think about this idea
it's not really any of um any of
anyone's business everyone should
keep themselves themselves and idea i
don't believe that you should
have to display that information i don't
think i'd want to go out with someone
who
refused the vaccine i guess for a number
of reasons um
anti-vaxxers it's kind of a and um
yeah i i if it said refused i think
that's quite like a would play a big
factor in
sure i'm swiping so this is all based on
trust there's no way of really knowing
if
it's being vaccinated so with anything
dating related it is a leap of faith
okay thank you thank you as questions
continue in england
over whether the 21st of june will in
fact be freedom day with a big easing of
restrictions
islands making a big shift back towards
a more normal
way of life today and our island
correspondent stephen murphy is
with us now in dublin hello to you
stephen i think one of my twitter
followers told me yesterday that it's a
public holiday in ireland today is that
right
yes it's a bank holiday monday uh okay
here in ireland that's why it's so
quiet here at the gym um basically here
at dirty health club the
which is open for the first time today
since december this is one of the first
in fact it is the first class you can
see they're wearing a sign of disco
technology that's because we're in a
residential area
and it's seven o'clock on a bank holiday
monday so they don't want booming music
coming out but these guys are among the
first in the country to get back
into a gym from today we will see the
return of jim's
swimming pools there's one inside here
uh cinemas and theaters can reopen
and as well the one that many people
will be looking forward to the return of
outdoor hospitality so later on
today we'll see all the um pubs that
have been shot since december
reopening for outdoor hospitality as
well as
restaurants as well of course people
will remember this happened back in
december and it led to a third
wave of cases a really bad third wave so
people would be very cautious
and keeping an eye on the data but
certainly from this morning it is really
a big and quite an exciting day here
in ireland i'm guessing you must have
already done your workout which is why
you're not
working along with them
i wouldn't fit into my gym gear to be
honest after the last few months okay i
need to go shopping i think
welcome to my world it's good to see you
thank you uh also
a further easing of restrictions in
wales for you this morning under new
rules up to 30 people will now be able
to meet in parks and gardens
while three households can meet indoors
larger organized events such as concerts
and football matches will resume for up
to 4 000 people
standing and 10 000 people if they're
sat down
looking at the latest coronavirus
figures for the uk for you this morning
5
341 new coronavirus cases have been
reported
in the most recent 24-hour period four
deaths were reported which means the
total number of people who've died
within
28 days of a positive test now stands
at 127 840.
meanwhile another 203 613 people have
received
their first vaccination and 473
378 people have now received their
second it means that 40 million people
in the uk
have now received a first dose of a
coronavirus
vaccine time for a look at this
morning's other main stories for you
and more than 30 people reported to have
been killed after two express trains
collided in southern pakistan
it's thought more than 20 people are
still trapped in the wreckage
the prime minister imran khan has
expressed his concern
over the incident and says he is
ordering a comprehensive
investigation into railway safety
the england bowler ollie robinson has
been suspended from all international
cricket pending the outcome of an
investigation into racist and sexist
tweets he posted
as a teenager he won't be available for
selection for a second test match
against new zealand
later this week the islamic state west
african province militant group has said
the leader of rival nigerian militant
group islamic bokeh haram has
died abu bakr shekau is believed to have
self-detonated an explosive device while
being pursued
by islamic state militants on the 18th
of may
back home the big winner at last night's
bafta tv awards was
michaela cole for her abuse drama i may
destroy you and she used her acceptance
speech to call on the industry to do
more
to stamp out the abuse of power there
was a win for sky news 2
in the best news coverage category for
inside
idlib our entertainment correspondent
lucy cossa reports
in the wake of the allegations against
noel clarke it was no surprise michaela
cole
creator and star of i may destroy you
the hit series about consent
who won both best actress and best
miniseries
alluded to abuse when picking up her
award
calling on the industry to make
productions safer and thanking her own
intimacy coordinator for doing just that
thank you for your existence in our
industry for making
the space safe for creating physical
emotional
and professional boundaries so that we
can make work
about exploitation loss of respect about
abuse of power
without being exploited or abused in the
process
bafta's virtual audience announcing the
only award voted for by the public
can you announce can you see that right
after you
diversity's black lives matter inspired
dance routine on britain's got talent
which prompted more than 30 000
complaints
took the prize and following
unprecedented change by bafta to improve
diversity
originality and risk-taking was rewarded
thank you so much sky arts for being so
brave
and so pioneering putting on british tv
the first spoken word poetry show sky
news took best news coverage
somehow the elderly owner walks out
alive
couldn't produce a program like inside
idlib without a huge
group of talented dedicated passionate
journalists and we had those in bucket
loads
and along with the greatest tv moments
of the year there was a nod to the
realities of working from home
and a celebration of when things go
wrong as well as right
yes yes you can have two biscuits lucy
sky news
let's return to our top story for you
now a group of conservative party mps
hope to force boris johnson to reverse
cuts to the foreign aid budget
in a vote this afternoon joining us from
wigan
is the shadow foreign secretary lisa
nandy hello to you ms nandy thanks for
joining us on the programme
this morning apparently the chancellor's
digging in he's been ringing rebels over
the weekend and he is determined
that this 0.5 for foreign aid will stay
in place
i think the government is making a real
mistake they're about to go into
the most important week for many many
months
the g7 which the uk is hosting with a
major plank of global britain
in tatters and he could change his mind
he could
reverse this he could just admit that
cutting global aid in the middle of a
pandemic
is the wrong thing to do it's
short-sighted
it's not in britain's interest and he
could he could solve this very very
quickly
i think the rebels are keen to make sure
that they
they stay together as a party um i think
they want
to see it the g7 be a success we
certainly do
and so it would be in the prime
minister's interest it be in britain's
interest if they
if they just admitted they got this one
wrong
and moved on and started focusing on the
g7 which is really really important
where we could reach a global agreement
about how to attack auckland 19.
and we'll come on to that but it does
appear that on the face of it the
opposition's out of step
with public opinion 60 of uh public when
asked
support what the government is doing in
other words saying charity starts at
home we haven't got the money
at the moment but but that's the point
0.7
of uh gni is um the reason that we
formulated it like that when we were in
government and the reason why david
cameron's government
and theresa may's government backed that
policy is because we spend what we can
afford
on foreign aid so when the country is
struggling we spend less and when the
country is doing well we spend
more so we spent 700 million less
in 2020 than we did in 2019 for
precisely that reason
and these are programs that fund things
like
tackling covid19 they fund things like
tackling climate change they fund things
like tackling isis
these are programs that aren't just the
right thing to do
they're also in britain's interest as
well we also um
fund countries like china that actually
doesn't need our money
well look there are a number of
programmes that fund countries like
china and india for example trying to
prevent um tsunamis and natural
disasters from taking place
and there's a lot of nonsense talked
about what that money is for
but it's actually to try and forge
better relationships links with the
chinese people
with the indian people and britain is
renowned as a world leader in this this
is one of the things that gives us
soft power and influence around the
world
it's really important that we continue
to fund programmes
that make make us stronger in the world
that
give us more influence that allow us to
have a direct relationship with people
in countries where we have
serious disagreements with their
governments but where we want to support
their efforts to advance democracy and
the rule of
law and human rights and that's why
there are so many conservative mps today
saying to the government look you've
just
you've got this wrong and nobody wants
to see
us going into this week of all weeks
this historic week
with the global britain policy and
tatters with a major row
on the government benches be far better
if they just dropped this
and said we've got this one wrong and
let's move on
that wasn't enough he's also got to
contend boris johnson with the leader of
the free world who's coming down to
cornwall for the g7
at the weekend and he has said that
apparently shot across the bows
unless you sort out this mess that is uh
the border in the north
in the irish sea if you will then there
ain't going to be no trade deal between
the uk
and the united states how does the
government get themselves out of this
what would labour suggest
well look i mean we've got to sort out
the border in the irish sea not because
joe biden has told us to but because
it's the right thing to do it's causing
absolute havoc in northern ireland and
we've got a responsibility to get this
right the prime minister made promises
to the people of northern ireland that
just haven't been kept i think the best
way to resolve this really is
through um decent relationships through
investing in those relationships and
through pragmatism we need to make sure
that we minimise any kind of border
checks and disruption
and we can do that with goodwill on both
sides in the last few weeks i've spoken
to
counterparts in many european countries
i think that goodwill
would be forthcoming but there's a
feeling at the moment
that the government is just missing in
action on this
particularly the prime minister whenever
there's been a need to
um to resolve issues in northern ireland
it's been
the british prime minister who has had
to personally step forward
and invest in making sure that that
happens boris johnson has created this
problem
and yet is nowhere to be seen i think
there's a real feeling of dismay about
that but he could turn that around
if he were prepared to step up convene
an intergovernmental
conference and get this um these
negotiations back up and running
uh what should we do about freedom day
um well i i mean i'm desperate for
us to unlock like many people around
this country particularly
i'm sitting here in wigan we've been an
almost continuous lock down here for the
last 14 months
but we've got a couple of weeks to go
and
we've got to get infection rates down
they're rising here they're rising in
bolton
blackburn berry these are all areas that
have asked the government for help and
that help hasn't been forthcoming
he needs to get the vaccine rolled out
as quickly as possible
to all over 18s he needs to listen to
public health officials who are saying
make it available to teenagers as well
because there's a real problem
um amongst um young people um which is
driving the spike in transmissions in
areas
like mine um if if he does that if he
listens to the front line
and if he puts those resources in place
if he closes um the loopholes in the
borders particularly this amber list
which is confusing
dangerous causing real real problems if
he does that
then we may be able to unlock in a few
weeks time and i desperately hope that
we can
my director ben is very impressed with
the way you frame your shot there ms
nandy and if you've had enough of being
an mp you can come and work in our
studio for us
this is very exciting okay i'm sitting
in the loft at the moment because
it's the only place that my six-year-old
can't get to but i will i will bear this
in mind for my um
my immediate future exactly you're going
to be locked down there's no better
place than we're good it's good to talk
to you lisa and andy thank you
thank you tomorrow's were the thoughts
well
labour will be thrilled with a
government defeat this afternoon if
there is a vote and if it goes
their way interesting point though you
made about the polling opinion polls do
show that the public think that we are
in a dire financial situation here
and it's the right decision to cut back
a bit we're still spending 10 billion
pounds
this year so is this the victory that
labour want i mean they and the
conservative rebels would say look
governments have to decide what the
right thing to do is
even if it may not be the very popular
thing sometimes
it's the right thing but i think the
prime minister and the chancellor will
be very aware
that the public according to those polls
anyway
are with them on this cut but they may
be forced into changing course
have to say though if the vote happens
and it doesn't go their way and you have
mps having voted for a cut
that does leave them in a difficult
situation going forward as well and just
very quickly the thought
from the government minister um on the
brexit
issues yes lord frost who negotiated
boris johnson's brexit deal uh which
created
um that the situation in northern
ireland the border essentially in the
irish sea has now said today in an
editorial in the financial times
we underestimated what a big problem
that would be for businesses
in terms of paperwork that's quite a big
admission we remember boris johnson
saying
anyone tells you to fill in a form
northern ireland businesses you can
throw it in the bin
turns out that's not what happened and
the government minister there admitted
it was more difficult on the ground
than we thought this is something that
lord frost now wants the eu
to back down on some of their
requirements this is going to be a very
tricky one to resolve and many will be
saying to the government we told you so
all ahead of the g7 uh in cornwall this
weekend tomorrow thanks very much indeed
thanks a lot
uh you saw what uh the weather with nasa
a little bit earlier on should give you
a little bit of a taste of what's
coming up she's with us with more detail
now looking fantastic in
burnt orange i'm going to call that
now's good morning
a bit of a sunshine color because we are
going to be seeing some good spells of
sunshine for today but
there will be some sharp showers for
some areas
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
good morning plenty of fine weather
around once again for today some good
spells of sunshine
warmth as well but into this afternoon
some sharp showers are going to be
developing in fact already this morning
there are some showers scattered across
parts of northern and eastern england
over western parts of ireland and
scotland there's also some showery rain
otherwise it's a mainly dry and bright
start but it is quite murky still across
southern counties of england and wales
and around some eastern parts of the uk
as well the murky conditions will mostly
lift and clear but i think around some
eastern coastal areas down towards
the south coast of kent it's still quite
murky and cool but inland parts
seeing lots of sunshine developing into
this afternoon but at the same time
there will be
more showers especially around northern
and eastern parts of england eastern
areas of scotland particularly for the
southeast scotland
further west though mainly dry except
for western ireland cloudy and down
there
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
the former prime minister gordon brown
calling for wealthier nations to do
more to help to vaccinate the global
population
writing in the mirror this morning he
says british people understand that no
one is safe until
everyone is safe and that kovid 19 is
not
over anywhere until it is over
everywhere
the joint says now hello to you mr brown
it's always great to see you thanks for
joining us
this morning what more do we need to do
in the uk to help with that
well it's pretty clear that we need to
vaccinate the world we're not safe
until everybody's safe as i said and
it's an act of self-interest it's not
just an act of charity
because if the disease spreads and
mutates and comes back into our country
through india nepal or africa then we
all suffer so this
is something that the world has got to
do together and that's why on friday
when boris johnson meets the g7 and
cornwall
they've got the chance the richest
countries sitting around the table
they've got the chance to make a
decision
that will vaccinate the whole world by
putting up the money that is necessary
to pay for it and
sharing the doses that are excess in the
united kingdom
but isn't that what the british
government is already doing they aren't
they putting forward 100 million
doses and saying that they're hoping
that the world will be vaccinated by the
end of next year
yeah that's not a plan there are 10
billion vaccines that are needed
100 million is one percent even if
america does it and other countries do
it
we're only scratching the surface you
can have a plan there okay you know that
every family knows that
you've got to have a plan to underwrite
the funding then you've got to get the
manufacturing capacity ramped up
then you've got to get it in a number of
different continents uh
manufacturing plants like africa and
then you can vaccinate the world it
needs a plan
not just a wing and a prayer and a few
doses that are left over being handed
over
that's a good thing but it's not enough
but these doses are already being
manufactured manufactured i should say
around the world aren't they not least
in places like india
yes india the serum institute but
there's not much being done in africa
and so something's got to happen in
africa which is a billion people as you
know
and then we've got to make sure that the
whole world is is covered so
you need to give the incentive as we did
in britain when we offered to
pre-purchase vaccines
we got britain covered but we need to
offer to pre-purchase vaccines for the
whole world
and there's a mechanism for doing that
there's a thing called kovacs it's an
international fund
they will pre-order the vaccines if they
have the money
and the money has got to be put on the
table on friday
a dose per second uh in the developed
world i believe
is what's being administered at the
moment but less than two percent of the
population
in africa has presently had uh their
first dose of whichever
vaccination is being offered one of the
other problems though
is the population wanting to have these
doses in the first place so it is about
communication too
yes i think we've got to realize there
are teething problems they're
getting the supply up and running
they're also distribution and logistics
problems and there's also this worry
particularly of course
when the publicity from the french
president about astrazeneca was put
around the world
uh that some vaccines are not safe
enough so we've got to get over these
problems
but that can be done if we can convince
the leaders in the country
to mount not just a vaccine campaign but
a publicity campaign
to explain the benefits of vaccination
you know it is so important that
children are vaccinated against
poorly on diphtheria and all these
things and that's at risk through these
overseas aid cuts
but it's equally important that every
adult is vaccinated as soon as possible
and the end of 2022 is not good enough
we've got to get a bit quicker than that
you mentioned the overseas aid cuts from
0.7 percent of gdp down to 0.5
it is only temporary according to the
government and we just can't afford to
pay any more
at this stage it does appear that 60
percent of the british population
agree with the government so it's uh
people like you lisa nandy
and other opposition representatives who
are out of step
not rishi sunak that's very
interesting okay but there's a poll this
morning which says something quite
different
that 79 of the british people when asked
about their preference
want britain to pay its fair share of
vaccinating the world
and only 21 are against so when it comes
to vaccines and people realize
the benefit for the whole world but
particularly also the benefit to britain
people actually 79 want us to pay our
fair share so
i think you've got to look at these
overseas aid cuts and think
if you're pulling away the vaccine or
the injection needle
from children and adults who need
vaccinated and putting their lives at
risk
then that's not a good thing and there
is not public support for that
and on friday at the g7 we will decide
effectively who lives and who dies
who is to be vaccinated and is therefore
safe and who is not to be vaccinated
and therefore is at risk how are you
feeling about vaccinations for kids
in the uk remember i mean i can't
remember how old your children are now
they're always toddlers when i think
about them but have they
are you happy for them to have their
vaccinations
yes of course and and they're they're
teenagers and
if the medical advice is that the
teenagers
and young children have got to be
vaccinated then we should do
so but i do say there is enough uh
potential for producing vaccine around
the world
so you don't have to make a choice
between vaccinating the 12 year old
and vaccinating older people and nurses
and health workers in other countries
we've got to be able to do both and
that's the importance of having a plan
and i've set out a plan
norway and south africa have put this
plan forward as well
that the g7 can make sure that everybody
is vaccinated
by making a decision on friday not not
just hoping through door sharing
but funding it to make sure it actually
happens and i don't think there's a
family in this country who will say
that children and adults in other
countries who need it should not have
vaccines
but let me just talk about families in
this country if i may
you and sarah are very happy for your
children to have their vaccinations
what would you say to other parents
listening this morning taking their kids
off to school thinking
it's okay for me to have the double jab
but i'm not sure it's proven
this vaccine yet for my youngster
well i said medical advice if the
medical advice
is that we should have it then i will
accept the medical advice
and i think the prime minister and the
government ministers will will do so
and if the advice is given in such a way
that it reassures people
then i think most parents who get their
children vaccinated for other things for
tuberculosis for polio
for diphtheria uh all these vaccinations
parents are prepared to do that for the
children meningitis as well
then we should make sure it happens it's
really a question of following
the best medical advice we have and a
quick thought before i let you go as far
as politics is concerned the brexit
minister writing in the financial times
this morning
and saying hmm it's a bit harder than
they thought it was going to be this
border in the north sea what the irish
sea i should say what would you say in
response
well we're going to be paying the price
for many years to come because
our trade is affected imports and
exports
are affected northern ireland is
particularly affected
and i really hope the government can
sort out some of these problems as
quickly as possible
because it's about jobs it's about
livelihoods it's about the supply of
food and everything else it's got to be
sorted out
21st of june um freedom day are you all
in favor
well everybody wants uh all the
restrictions to end
but we've got to do it on the basis of
medical advice i mean i think
we've listened to the um very senior
health
advisors throughout this crisis and we
should continue to listen to them
and there will be an end to this if we
do the right things okay
always a pleasure to talk to you mr
brown thank you so much for joining us
on the program this morning thank you
let's put that to sir david king should
we he's the former chief scientific
advisor and chair of the independence
sage
group hello to you just heard what the
former prime minister had
to say then um if not the 21st then when
well i think i think first of all kate
what i want to do is take you through
some numbers
today we we've had announced 5
300 cases per day new cases of the
disease per day in the united kingdom
and last week comparison means we're up
about 2000 on last week now we've been
discussing whether or not we're going
into a serious
third wave and i don't think we can
possibly wait any longer
this is the evidence of another wave of
appearing
and the reason is quite complex uh it is
yes the vaccination program is working
extremely well
and everyone supports it why we haven't
ramped up production so that we can meet
our demand and
international demand is an issue that we
need to discuss
because certainly we could have had that
capacity built up
but what what i i do think is important
is that we know that anyone
vaccinated twice is relatively safe
against the
virus but let's not forget that
the 1 in 25 new cases are people who
have been vaccinated twice
that means 400 new cases a day
are people who have had the vaccine
twice so i i just want to say
while there is an extensive amount of
virus
out there in the country amongst our
people
it is dangerous and
sorry to interrupt you david but the
government would say in response to that
yes you potentially could um get covered
even though you've had two vaccinations
but the likelihood
of you dying as a result of that is uh
infinitesimal
well we don't yet know that we we
haven't had the indian variety for long
enough to be able to say it's
infinitesimal
but what i would say is that dying isn't
the sole issue
about that we're trying to avoid here
the number of people who are suffering
from long covert in the country
is enormous and so this is not
a simply a flu once you've had the
vaccine
i don't think we can underestimate the
importance of this disease
and of course we know that it's
spreading rapidly amongst children who
haven't been vaccinated and you've just
been saying
to gordon brown would you have your
children vaccinated
actually the uh the the
visa vaccine has already been given the
green light
in this country to over 12 year olds
i think we should run that program
forward quickly
but you see we we're opening schools
today
and the government has said 12 to 18
year olds no longer need to wear masks
face masks at school
i don't think that was a wise thing to
do and i do hope the government would
rethink this
in the light of the current figures let
me just say about
the number of people in our hospitals
which the government says is relatively
stable
well it's 932 per day going into
hospital
which is up 65 from last week it's not
actually stable
it is slowly rising so what what all of
this
means is that intensive care is needed
for a significant proportion of our
population today
i do think i'm i'm very reluctant to say
that we should not
go out of lockdown on the 21st of june
but i think the figures
are in now and it would be wise for the
government
to announce right away a delay in
opening just so that we can all plan
for the post 21st of june period a delay
for how long sir david
i would give it a few weeks delay and
see how the figures are emerging
so i don't know how long as the
prime minister has said it's data not
dates that we should be governed by
and that's my response to you as well
i wish i could predict but everything
depends now
on how well the government manages this
program
frankly we haven't managed it at all
well
today why aren't we separating people
who have the disease from those who
don't
the find test trace and supported
isolate system
that works so well in so many countries
has simply not been up and running in
this country
that is the way for us to get on with
our business
manage the economy and at the same time
open up
if we can separate those people from the
rest of us
but of course that has failed and the
government isn't even talking
about trying to make this work why do we
talk about testing
at large scale if the purpose of the
testing
isn't to see that we isolate those who
have the disease from those who don't
uh final thoughts david before i let you
go i suppose the government would say
in response to to the information that
you're giving us today
they have to take into consideration not
just covid19
but people that are dying from all sorts
of other illnesses
as well and indeed the mental health of
lots of people
in the nation who really just cannot
bear the thought
of not being able to be released from
lockdown on the 21st of june what would
you say in response to that
well i think the first thing to say in
response is that
the the economy is going to be better
off
if we open up quickly but at the same
time if we open up too quickly the
economy will suffer if if i then look at
the state of our hospital
the number of people who are waiting for
operations is larger than we have on
record for a very very long time
as soon as we can get this virus out of
the country
then we can get the hospitals back up
and running but here again
surely there should be a campaign for
the government
to fund the nhs properly there hasn't
been a significant increase in funding
to the
national health services since this
whole outbreak began
and i would say that again is is a
missing parameter
since 2010 we have seen funding of nhs
being cut back
that really needs to be recovered in
order to manage
all of the health issues in the country
now you're talking about
people who are suffering mentally
and i do think that's absolutely right
from being in lockdown
and we are now in a semi lockdown and
that is already helping
and i'm i'm going out to dinner for the
first time tonight
you know so we we all want this uh this
new situation
to arise but i don't see the government
doing nearly enough
to manage this and nor have i seen have
i seen this
since the beginning of this outbreak let
me ask
you if i may to ask the government
are they actually believing in herd
immunity among school children
is that why they're saying take masks
off
so that the disease spreads rapidly and
they all become immune by having had the
disease
is if that is a policy shouldn't we
be honest with the public and tell us
that is the policy
i believe that herd immunity was the
policy from the beginning
back in february march last year so have
we returned to that now with a high
vaccination
level so i i've got many many questions
to ask the government well i'll try and
do that on your behalf next time i get
the opportunity it's good to talk to you
hopefully a cheeky glass of wine with
that dinner tonight as well it's good to
talk to you thanks a lot
thank you they'll be celebrating in
california today because harry and megan
have announced the birth of a baby girl
whose name
pays tribute to her great grandmother
the queen and her late grandmother
princess diana we're joined now by the
royal editor
of the sunday times that's ryan nika
hello to roy it's great to see you tell
us about the significance of the name
good morning kay well both names are
hugely significant
and i think most of us role watchers
thought there might be elizabeth in
there but lily bette is that very
intimate childhood nickname that only
those closest to the queen have used for
her
of course including the late duke of
edinburgh so i think the significance of
choosing that name for
for their daughter's first name is i
think it shows that they're very keen to
let the world know that despite
the very turbulent year harry and megan
have had and
the complaints they've made against the
monarchy there is still a very close
bond and a close tie
with her majesty the queen so do you
think that this is in some way
trying to heal the rift or perceived
rift between
the couple the other side of the united
states
and her majesty and the other members of
the royal family here
it definitely feels like a symbolic move
um yes i think you know every explosion
that's come from across the pond in the
last over the last sort of six months or
two a year or so
the queen has made a series of
statements dating back to when they
decided to leave
to you know the most recent interview
with oprah
and every time she's made a statement
she has she has continued to say
harry megan and archie remain much loved
members of my family and i think
choosing this name uh you know which
everyone will recognize as being a very
close personal name of the queens
is a sign from the couple that i think
they want people to acknowledge that
they still have that close bond
um and a lot of love and respect for the
queen and that they are very much still
part of the windsor dynasty
isn't harry supposed to be coming over
to um
unveil a statue of his mom with his
brother for her
60th birthday i think first of july or
thereabouts is that still going to
happen do you think
yes i i think um my understanding is he
is still due over here so of course
given the uh uh isolation things we need
to do at the moment
i think we can expect to see him travel
within the next few weeks
uh and he is due to unveil that statute
which william and harry commissioned
together
four years ago when of course the
relationship between the brothers and
the royal family was was very different
but you know also giving their daughter
diana as her second name it all feels
quite close and and
close to home the moment isn't quite
personal and i think that will be on
everyone's minds when the two of them
unveiled that statue on july the 1st of
what would have been her 60th at
kensington palace
everybody will be looking at the body
language between the boys um
when that happens what do you know about
their relationship at the moment
um it's still not great
is my understanding i i think
despite that both william and harry know
that that moment
is a huge global moment and that moment
has to be about their mother's memory
so in the same way they did for the duke
of edinburgh's funeral i'm absolutely
certain they will put any
um hurt and differences aside for that
day to make sure that it goes off well
um and they honor their mother in the
way that they wanted to with that statue
so i don't think we should expect to see
any foidio
or distance there but there's no doubt
that you know a lot of the media will be
scrutinizing every single movement they
make at that unveiling
and just back to baby lily bet for uh a
final comment will she get some sort of
royal title or not
she will but not yet and i suppose
slightly poignant because she will get
that title she will get an hrh she will
be a princess
but only when the queen is no longer
monarch and when the prince of wales
ascends to the throne
she and archie will automatically be
elevated to hr ages
okay it's good to talk to you thank you
so there you go the baby was born on
friday afternoon we're told
mom baby and dad all doing well
um what's happening as far as the
weather is concerned today as you can
see
nazi's looking resplendent in burnt
orange does that reflect on what the
weather's going to be doing now good
morning
good morning good morning a bit of
orange weather
well sunshine is what i meant for today
but we are also going to see some
[Music]
showers
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning some good spells of
sunshine will be developing for today
again
i will be feeling warm as well but there
will be some sharp
showers around currently some showers
are scattered across some northern and
eastern parts of england also
western coast of ireland and scotland
otherwise it's a mainly dry and bright
start but there are some
fairly murky conditions across southern
parts of england and wales and around
eastern parts of the uk as well most of
the murky conditions
will burn away so we will see some good
spells of sunshine developing
particularly around inland areas for
today but around eastern parts of
scotland
the south east of england as well i
think it will stay quite murky and cool
and there will be sharp showers for
northern and eastern england
and eastern parts of scotland